you know what I learned this movie being
on Roku I learned that nothing is Roku
friendly at all so instead of being able
to cast the movie from my phone onto my
TV or stream it through my TV you know
like a normal 2022 human being I had to
hook up my laptop via HDMI to my
television it's inspiring in a way to
have a 2008 setup in 2022. anyhow that's
my old man energy for the day let's do
this
[Music]
so weird the Al Yankovic story is a
Weird Al
biopic in which it tells ish the story
of Weird Al's life kind of now do I love
Weird Al yes there are reported 195
countries in the world and I guarantee
you all of them consider Weird Al a
National Treasure not here to flex but I
do know all the words to dare to be
stupid
it's a weird flex but real so I was
interested in watching this biopic about
his life stay with me on this one I
hadn't seen the trailer I heard about
the movie coming out in fact I recently
heard about how this is essentially like
the movie Machete and explaining that
comparison it was a fake trailer that
turned into a movie but instead of
taking you know a couple years like
machete this took about 10 it was close
to 10. it was 9 or 10 years ago on Funny
or Die they had a fake Weird Al trailer
and that trailer became this movie in
fact in this movie like machete you do
see the scenes where you're like that's
from the fake trailer Daniel Radcliffe
is Weird Al he's likable he's relatable
he's comedic also dramatic but also has
to be comedic even when being dramatic
in this film it's still comedic so I'm
gonna go ahead and call this a 100
comedic performance Rayne Wilson is Dr
Demento which I was appreciating all of
this before I really realized what this
movie was you see at a point in watching
this film you're gonna be like yeah
they're embellishing they're
exaggerating as biopics do but if you
know nothing of about this movie this
movie eventually massages you into the
reality of the situation where you're
like this isn't as much of a biopic as
it is a parody oh
oh yeah that makes sense the time it
takes for the viewer to realize this
fact will vary from Individual to
individual but if you don't realize it
by the last act you're either going to
be very confused are you going to go
through the rest of your life thinking
that Weird Al was a military badass and
I actually did appreciate this about
this movie I can't help but feel a
little disappointed that it's not an
actual look into Weird Al's life you
know it's not a it's not a real biopic
but I appreciate the fact that in the
world we're all biopics make things up
for the sake of dramatic effect this
movie makes sure that by the end you
understand it did that too and it
actually uses it for comedy and doesn't
hide it at all and the reason they did
that for this movie is probably a very
simple one it's because Weird Al Just he
comes across as a really chill dude that
just wants to parody music Someone you'd
want to hang out with I guarantee you
most people have scripts about their
lives that they want to be turned into
movies and the conversation probably
goes down something like this hey you
get the script about my life uh yeah
yeah I did are we allowed to embellish
it all or make no no no okay has been
100 legit you do realize that your life
like most people's lives is very boring
right
as I'm sure Weird Al was like my life
isn't that exciting so let's just have
fun with the premise let's parody and
spoof the musical artist biopic formula
which is gonna land if you're a Weird Al
fan dude if you're a Weird Al fan it's
gonna speak your language if you're not
a Weird Al fan you might be a little
lost in this joke but such is life it
actually kind of comes across like an
Andy Kaufman biopic really
no I'm not talking about man on the moon
I'm talking about if Andy Kaufman made a
biopic about his life and that film went
Splat with UHF
it's kind of this movie and in the end I
had a good time with it you can't treat
it like a biopic treat it like a comedy
in that it's
I feel like a proper biopic is more
relatable whereas this is a joke biopic
it comes across as like all right I'm
tuning in for a biopic and then this
comes on he's just like oh I'm being
Rick Rolled did I just show my age
what showed my age more the fact that I
could not get Roku to catch to my TV and
I had to hook up my laptop or the fact
that I just referenced being Rick Rolled
old man energy I don't hide it this is
undeniably a film for Weird Al fans so
not only are they gonna get the joke of
the movie as a whole but also it's fun
knowing the song that he's about to come
up with because of something someone
said or something he's about to do
you're like I take the pieces I know
where this is going you're not a Weird
Al fan moments like that that kind of
make the movie are gonna be lost on you
ironically though as biopics go this is
probably as accurate as most biopics out
there and that is kind of the funny part
to me but I did have fun with his Weird
Al biopic spoof again I would actually
like to have seen an actual biopic about
his life but in a world where Weird Al's
gonna take the joke I laughed at the
joke add myself a good time no alcohol
required all right so we're the Al
Yankovic story have you seen it what did
you think about it or what's your
favorite Weird Al memory whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]